اخبار العلم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم للاسبوع الثالث على التوالي
استمرار المظاهرات في مدينه السويداء
ودرعا الجنوبيه سوريا احتجاجا على ترد
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه وتطالب بتغيير سياسي
في حين نقلت وسائل اعلام محليه ان وسائل
النقل العام التابعه للحكومه امتنعت عن
نقل المتظاهرين من اطراف السويداء
للمشاركه في الاحتجاجات
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا الجيش
الاوكراني يعلن عن تقدمه في محاور عده
لاسيما في الشرق حيث تتواصل المعارك مع
القوات الروسيه وخدمه الطوارئ الاوكرانيه
تعلن سقوط عشرات القتلى والجرحى جراء قصف
روسي صاروخي بينما قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه انها تصدت لهجمات بطائرات مسيره
استهدفت اكثر من منطقه
الى جنوب لبنان حيث يسود الهدوء الحظ
المخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين الفلسطينيين
بعد تجدد الاشتباكات بين حركه فتح هو
مجموعه تسمي نفسها الشباب المسلم والتي
ادت الى جرح اكثر من 20 شخصا ونزوحي عشرات
العائلات وحركه حماس تعلن اجراء اتصالات
لوقف القتال وتقول انما يجري فتنه تقف
خلفها جهات مشبوهه
بعد تاثير عامين عن موعدها شركه تسلا
الامريكيه المملوكه لايلون ماسك تقترب من
طرح مركبه النقل الكهربائيه بالكامل سايبر
تراك وكان ماسك قد اكد ان المركبه ستكون
بمثابه قارب لفتره وجيزه وستكون قادره على
عبور الانهار والبحيرات وانه بمجرد طرحها
ستحدث ثوره على الطرقات بحسب قوله الى
اللقاء